THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. EVERYBODY
WE ARE HOLDING OUR HEARING TODAY
IN ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. I ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN THE HEARING. WE'RE GOING
TO BE A LITTLE SHORT HANDED
TODAY. WE'VE BEEN NOTIFIED THAT
SENATORS ASHBY AND WAHAB WILL BE
ABSENT AND THANKFULLY, SENATOR
NEAL WILL BE SITTING IN FOR
SENATOR SATO FOR THIS HEARING.
WELCOME TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR NEAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IT'S A DIFFICULT
TASK, BUT SOMEONE HAS TO DO IT.
WE HAVE 60 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. ALL MEMBERS
WITH BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION, WITH
ONE EXCEPTION. AND BUT IN IN ALL
OF THE CASES, WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH ITEM. I ALSO WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SB 1253 BY SENATOR
GONZALES IS STILL LISTED IN THE
DAILY FILE, BUT THAT MEASURE
WILL BE RESCHEDULED FOR OUR
HEARING NEXT WEEK. ADDITIONALLY,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
A FILE ON ANY OF THE MEASURES
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES WILL NOT BE HERE
TO PRESENT. BEFORE WE BEGIN, I
WANT TO REMIND THE WITNESSES TO
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL,
WHICH IS WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
DEALS WITH. AND PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS
AND REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR COMMENTS. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY ON THE MEASURES BEFORE US,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
ASSISTANTS, PLEASE. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
HERE. CABALLERO. HERE. JONES.
JONES HERE. ASHBY. BECKER.
BECKER. HERE BRADFORD. NILO.
HERE. NILO. HERE. WAHAB A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. NOW WE CAN
MOVE ON TO THE BUSINESS OF THE
DAY. SO, FIRST UP. IS SENATE
BILL 892 BY SENATOR PADILLA.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, AND SENATOR PADILLA
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE
PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 892?
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD, IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 892? NO
MOVEMENT AGAIN, THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 892 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 893 BY SENATOR PADILLA IS
THERE. SENATOR PADILLA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION THÀNH. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 893? SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE A
CANDIDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB
EIGHT 893 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1006 BY SENATOR
PADILLA, SENATOR PADILLA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1006? ANYBODY
HERE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1006? SEEING NONE. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1006 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1049 BY SENATOR PADILLA.
SENATOR PADILLA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN? 1049?
ANYBODY. ANYBODY HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB 1049? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1049 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
NEXT IS SB 1105, AGAIN BY
SENATOR PADILLA. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO. SENATOR
PADILLA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HELLO. MY
NAME IS YUSEF MILLER. I'M WITH
THE CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS AND THE
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE, ESP ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS, FACTS,
GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION AND SAFE
AGRICULTURE. SAFE SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB 1005? SEEING NO ONE, IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
MOVEMENT. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1105 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1241 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. IS THERE ANYBODY?
SENATOR PADILLA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. WELCOME, SIR. IN
SUPPORT YUSEF MILLER, NORTH
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION, CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS.
THE NORTH COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COALITION AND THE ESP
FACTS GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION
AND SAFE AGRICULTURE. SAFE KIDS
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB 1241? IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1241? SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1241 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 896 BY
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR DODD HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 896?
MADAM CHAIR, GOOD MORNING, CHRIS
MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF OF THE LÀ
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR DODD'S BILL,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 896?
SEEING NONE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 896 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1014
BY SENATOR DODD, SENATOR DODD
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCCAULEY ON BEHALF
OF HUMBOLDT, REDWOOD COMPANY AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR DODD'S BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1014?
SEEING NO OPPOSITION, THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1014 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1380 BY
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR DODD HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1380?
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. WELL
CARLOS MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION
CO-SPONSOR ON 1380, WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OBVIOUSLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1380? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1380 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 903 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
YUSEF MILLER, CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION, GRANDPARENTS
FOR ACTION NORTH COUNTY CLIMATE
CHANGE ALLIANCE, THE INTERFAITH
COALITION FOR EARTH JUSTICE, AND
SAFE AGRICULTURE, SAFE SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
903 BY SENATOR SKINNER? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. TIM
CIZEK WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR SILVIO
FERRARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION, WHO
HAS LABELED THIS A HOUSING
KILLER. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR ADAM WRIGLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AS A
JOB KILLER. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, BRETT GLADFELTER WITH
APEX GROUP ON BEHALF OF AGC
INCORPORATED. IN OPPOSITION. AND
GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS, ROB
SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THIS IS A
MANUFACTURING BREAKER AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
DENNIS ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF
SPAN, WE ARE OPPOSED ALSO ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS. WE REMAIN OPPOSED
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
YEAH. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 903
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SB 950 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO THOSE IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? YUSEF MILLER, CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION, THE
INTERFAITH COALITION FOR JUSTICE
, ESP, ECO SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS
, FACTS, GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION
AND SAFE AGRICULTURE, SAFE
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 950? SEEING NO OPPOSITION,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
950 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
907 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE OAN IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. TOM SHEEHY, ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION, THE STAFF ANALYSIS
HAS IDENTIFIED ALMOST $1 MILLION
IN COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
BILL, WHICH COMES FROM ADDING
NEW TRUSTEES, WHICH THAT WILL BE
A COST IN PERPETUITY, WHICH
COMES FROM REORGANIZING ORANGE
COUNTY'S ELECTION PROCESS AND
WHICH COMES FROM A NEW
REDISTRICTING PROCESS, WHICH
THIS BILL WILL TRIGGER BY ADDING
THE ADDITIONAL TRUSTEES, ALL OF
THOSE COSTS ARE GOING TO ADD UP
TO OVER $1 MILLION. LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HAS KEYED THIS AS A
MANDATE, WHICH MEANS THAT THIS
COST WILL ULTIMATELY BE BORNE
FROM THE STATE GENERAL FUND. AND
WITH RESPECT TO THE TRUSTEE
COST, THAT MEANS THE GENERAL
FUND WILL BE PAYING FOR THOSE
TRUSTEES AND THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE AND THEIR PER DIEM AND
ALL THE REST OF IT IN
PERPETUITY. IT ALSO MEANS THAT
ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS WILL BE
PAYING FOR THE COST OF THESE
TRUSTEES. DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY,
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THIS BILL BE HELD ON SUSPENSE
WHEN THE TIME COMES. THANK YOU.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION, MR. TIM
SHAW. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
TIM SHAW, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION, OUR BOARD UNANIMOUSLY
TOOK A POSITION TO OPPOSE SENATE
BILL 907. AS MR. SHEEHY
INDICATED, IT IS A VERY COSTLY
BILL THAT WE FIND TO BE,
FRANKLY, UNNECESSARY. WE
RECENTLY WENT THROUGH OUR
REDISTRICTING PROCESS. WE DIDN'T
HEAR A SINGLE COMMENT ABOUT
ADDING TRUSTEES OR CHANGING THE
TIME OF OUR ELECTIONS. SO IT'S
NOT REALLY BEEN AN ISSUE FOR US
IN ORANGE COUNTY. SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR, YOU
TO HOLD THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY, THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 907 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1080 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1080? YUSEF MILLER, NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO
POWAY INTERFAITH TEAM AND
ESCONDIDO TOGETHER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1080? SEEING NONE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1080 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1171 BY SENATOR NEWMAN SEN.
NEWMAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1171? IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1171? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1171 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AS
SB 1263 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL. SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1263? SEEING
NEITHER THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1263 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 945 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL. SENATOR ALVARADO
GIL HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCCAULEY ON BEHALF
OF HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
945? SEEING NO ONE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 945 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1396 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF HER BILL?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1396. SEEING NO TESTIMONY. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE. FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE IT TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THÀNH. AND
THAT'S 1396. MOVING ON TO SB 951
BY SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR
WIENER HAS WAIVED THE
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 951? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 951?
SEEING NO NO TESTIMONY, THE BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 951 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 988 BY
SENATOR WIENER. IS THERE,
SENATOR WIENER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL AS
WELL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF 988? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 988? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 988 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 987 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 987? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 987?
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR WILLIE
PAUL. ON BEHALF OF ACP, SB LOCAL
9685 AND AC LOCAL 1967, IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION, THE BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
987. WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1112 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF HER BILL? YUSEF
MILLER, CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS,
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS, FACTS,
GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION AND SAFE
AGRICULTURE, SAFE SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 1112?
SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1112 WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1193 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON THIS BILL, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESS TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? YUSEF MILLER, CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION, THE NORTH
COUNTY CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE,
FACTS GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION,
SAFE AGRICULTURE, SAFE SCHOOLS
AND NURSES, CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1193? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1193 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 996 BY
SENATOR WILK. SENATOR WILK HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 998? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
SB 998? SEEING NO TESTIMONY. I'M
SORRY, SB 996. LET'S START THAT
OVER. ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF SB
996? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
996? THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 996 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO SB TEN
NINE 1029 BY SENATOR MINH.
SENATOR MINH HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1029? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1029? SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1029 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1078 BY
SENATOR MINH. SENATOR MINH HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? YUSEF MILLER
, CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS, NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE,
GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION AND SAFE
AGRICULTURE, SAFE SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE, ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1078? SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1078 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1378 BY
SENATOR MINH. SENATOR MINH HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
AS WELL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1378? YUSEF MILLER
, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS, GRANDPARENTS FOR
ACTION, NORTH COUNTY CLIMATE
CHANGE ALLIANCE, AND THE
INTERFAITH COALITION FOR EARTH
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1378? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1378 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1041 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. SENATOR
PORTANTINO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1041? ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
1041? SEEING NONE. NEITHER OF
THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1041 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO SKIP THE
NEXT PRESENTATION. THE NEXT
BILL, MY UNDERSTANDING IS
SENATOR GROVE WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT ON HER BILL. SO WE'LL
WAIT UNTIL SHE GETS HER. MOVING
ON TO SB 1066 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPARE. SENATOR BLAKE SPARE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN?
1066? YUSEF MILLER, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION,
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS, NORTH
COUNTY CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE,
INTERFAITH COALITION FOR EARTH
JUSTICE, GRANDPARENTS FOR
ACTION, SAFE AGRICULTURE, SAFE
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1066? SEEING NONE,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1066 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
1077 BY SENATOR BLAKE SPARE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPARE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1077? ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB 1077? SEEING
NEITHER THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1077 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1092 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPARE. SENATOR BLAKE SPARE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? YUSEF MILLER, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
ONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1092 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1082 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR EGGMAN HAS
WAIVED. PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1082? THERESA
COMSTOCK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1082?
SEEING NO OPPOSITION, THE BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1082 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1238 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1238? ANYBODY HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1238? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THÀNH SB 1238
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1108
BY SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH SENATOR
OCHOA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION AS
WELL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1108?
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1108? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1108 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1468
SENATOR OKOBOJI HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON HER BILL. IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1468? IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1468? SEEING NO TESTIMONY, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1468 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1143 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR ALLEN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1143? YUSEF
MILLER, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION, CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS, THE NORTH COUNTY
CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE,
GRANDPARENTS FOR ACTION, SAFE
AGRICULTURE, SAFE SCHOOLS, AND
INTERFAITH COALITION FOR EARTH
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NURSES. I'M SORRY, CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MIKE ROBSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF WORTHINGTON
ENTERPRISES. WE'RE A PRODUCER
THAT WOULD BE COVERED BY HAS
PRODUCTS COVERED BY THIS BILL.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S A GOOD BILL.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANKS. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1143? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1143 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1231 BY SENATOR ALLEN,
SENATOR ALLEN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1231? ANYONE IN
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1231? SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1231 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. LET ME GO BACK TO
SENATOR GROVE. WELL THIS
MORNING, SB 1043 BY SENATOR
GROVE. SHE IS HERE. WE'RE HAPPY
TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
THIS BILL. IT'S ONE OF OUR
CHILDREN'S PROTECTION PACKAGES
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF JOINT
AUTHORS ON FROM OUR SENATE
COLLEAGUES. AND SO I DO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB 1043, THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CHILDREN'S
TREATMENT ACT, WHICH WOULD
CREATE MORE TRANSPARENCY
SURROUNDING THE USE OF
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION ROOMS
IN SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS, ALSO KNOWN
AS STRIP OPS. SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN ARE HOUSED IN THESE
STRIPS, INCLUDING FOSTER YOUTH
WHO HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED WITH THIS
KNOWLEDGE, WE MUST REQUIRE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE CARE
FOR THESE VULNERABLE. THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION. THÀNH SB
1043 IS A SIMPLE TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE WHICH WILL REQUIRE DSS
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC A PUBLIC
DASHBOARD BY JANUARY 1ST, 2026
THAT DISPLAYS THE DATA AND USE
OF RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION
ROOMS IN STRIPS. THIS DATA WILL
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF INCIDENTS
WHEN RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION
WERE USED, THE DURATION OF TIME
AND IF THERE WERE ANY INJURIES
OR DEATHS. ALONG WITH OTHER
NECESSARY DATA. THIS IS ALL DATA
THAT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER STATUTE TO
COLLECT AND MAINTAIN. CURRENTLY
STRIPS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
DEBRIEF TO PATIENTS ANY TIME.
RESTRAINT. ANY TIME RESTRAINTS
OR SECLUSION ARE USED. SB 1043
WILL REQUIRE DSS TO INCLUDE ON
THE DASHBOARD A WRITTEN
DESCRIPTION OF THOSE DEBRIEFS,
INCLUDING THE IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION, EXCUSE ME,
EXCLUDING THE IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION OF ALL THOSE
INVOLVED, THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES HAS BEEN
INSTRUCTED THROUGH STATUTE.
AGAIN, IT'S ALREADY LAW TO MAKE
THE RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION USE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER, ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND MAINTAIN
THE DATA, THEY HAVE FAILED TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS. SINCE
THE CREATION OF STRIPS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PUBLIC
DASHBOARD WASN'T CREATED WHEN WE
HAD A BUDGET SURPLUS, AND NOW
THAT WE HAD A WE HAVE A BUDGET
DEFICIT. I DON'T WANT THAT TO BE
THE CONTINUED REASONS OF WHY
WE'RE NOT IMPLEMENTING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY. THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN UNDER THE
STATE'S CARE SHOULD BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY. MY OFFICE HAS
REPEATEDLY ASKED FOR THE COST
ESTIMATE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
FIND OUT HOW MUCH THE DASHBOARD
WOULD COST TO IMPLEMENT.
HOWEVER, WE WERE NOT PROVIDED
THIS INFORMATION UNTIL LATE
FRIDAY AFTERNOON. I LOOK FORWARD
TO SITTING DOWN WITH DSS AND
FINDING OUT IF THERE ARE ANY
COST SAVINGS AND MEASURES THAT
WE CAN IMPLEMENT IN ORDER TO
HELP REDUCE THIS UNBELIEVABLY
HIGH ESTIMATE OF $1.7 MILLION
FOR ITS IMPLEMENTATION AND $1.6
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR MAINTENANCE
, IT SEEMS INCREDIBLY HIGH AS AN
ESTIMATE FOR DSS, SINCE THEY'RE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION. DSS HAS STATED THAT
THEY WILL NEED THE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT, QUOTE,
DEVELOPMENT AND CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT OF THE DATA
COLLECTING METHODOLOGY TO
PERFORM DATA ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING AND RESPOND TO A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT OR PRA
REQUEST REGARDING DATA AND THE
PUBLIC DASHBOARD, AS WELL AS
COLLECT DATA FOR REPORTING AND
MANUAL RESTRAINT. USE DIRECTLY
FROM THE FACILITIES MEMBERS.
AGAIN, DSS IS ALREADY REQUIRED
TO BE COLLECTING AND MAINTAINING
THIS DATA. I'M INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED THAT THEY WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
POSITIONS TO PERFORM THESE
DUTIES. THEY SHOULD ALREADY BE
FULFILLING REQUIRED BY CURRENT
LAW. DASHBOARDS ARE CREATED
THROUGH OTHER STATE AGENCIES.
HAVE MUCH LOWER COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
MAINTENANCE. I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE DEPARTMENT TO SEEK OUT
SUPPORT FROM THOSE OTHER
AGENCIES, WHICH I'D BE GLAD TO
PROVIDE TO THEM SO THAT THEY
COULD LEARN HOW TO LOWER THEIR
COST. ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE DASHBOARDS,
SUCH AS THE ONE REQUIRED UNDER
SB 40 1043 MEMBERS. THIS MEASURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CHILDREN'S
TREATMENT, OTHER ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CHILDREN'S TREATMENT IS JUST
THAT A SIMPLE TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE. AND WE'RE ASKING DSS TO
ESTABLISH A PUBLIC DASHBOARD IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND CARING FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY INVESTED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BRINGING OUR YOUTH BACK
FROM OTHER STATES WHERE WE KNEW
AND FOUND OUT THAT THEY WERE
ABUSED. WE ACTED IMMEDIATELY,
INVESTED $8 MILLION TO BRING
THEM BACK. WE ARE NOW HOUSING
THEM IN STATE STREET, TPS. WE
ALREADY KNOW ON A DASHBOARD THAT
DSS ALREADY HAS THE COMPLAINTS.
BROKEN ARMS, BROKEN BONES, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE BEING PUT IN
SECLUSION ROOMS, BUT THEY DON'T
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION OF HOW
LONG THEY DON'T PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR HERE ON TRANSPARENCY. Kò.
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IS TO GET THIS INFORMATION
PROVIDED TO US. SO AS WE AS
POLICY MAKERS, IF WE NEED TO,
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION TO KEEP
THESE CHILDREN SAFE, THEN WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT BASED
ON CORRECT INFORMATION AND DATA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, AGAIN, I REALIZE THAT BECAUSE
OF THE COST ESTIMATES, IT'S
GOING TO GO ON SUSPENSE, BUT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. WELL, I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION, FOCUSING ON THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF IT. AND YOU
MAKE SOME REALLY GOOD POINTS
THERE, IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT.
AND I KNOW THAT YOUR PRIORITY
HAS BEEN PROTECTING CHILDREN, SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS. LET ME
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE FISCAL PART OF
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS. AND WE'LL TAKE
A LOOK AT IT AND BE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. AND JUST
BRIEFLY, ON OTHER AGENCIES, SB
928 REYES OF 2023 WAS CHAPTERED
SIGNED INTO LAW, IT WAS MINOR
COST, REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CREATE A DASHBOARD. SB 1145
LAYERED 2022 WAS CHAPTERED AGAIN
WITH FOR THE ARB, THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD, AND IT'S
APPROXIMATELY $210,000 FOR AN
INITIALIZED INITIALIZE THE
DASHBOARD AND ONGOING SERVICES.
AND I LOOK AT THE WAY THAT
GOVERNMENT IS RUN ON THE FISCAL
COMPONENT OF IT. AND, YOU KNOW,
WE ALL HAVE A HEAVIER WORKLOAD
IN OUR OFFICES IN APRIL THAN WE
DO IN DECEMBER. AND IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO BELIEVE THAT IF WE
REQUIRE OUR ALLEGED DIRECTOR OR
OUR CHIEF OF STAFF OR OUR
SCHEDULER TO GO OUTSIDE OF THEIR
WORK CAPACITY TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED DONE IN APRIL
BECAUSE OF THE WORKLOAD THAT WE
HAVE, THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO DO THAT.
OUR STAFF JUMPS IN, GETS THE JOB
DONE. I DON'T KNOW WHY WE HAVE
TO CONTINUALLY FUND ADDITIONAL
TASKS FOR STATE AGENCIES, AS WE
SHOULD PROBABLY LOOK AT THAT AS
A BODY, TOO, BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF OUR
EXPENSE COMES IN OUR BUDGET. BUT
THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR,
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO LET ME
PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE,
YES. WE DO NEED TO SEE IF
THERE'S SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
THÀNH. IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB 1043?
YUSEF MILLER, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO AND CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
1043? IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1043?
SEEING NONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1043 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON, SB 1332 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. SENATOR ALLEN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1332? ANYONE
WHO IS HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1332. SEEING NEITHER THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1332
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1406
BY SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR ALLEN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1406? ANY BODY HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
1406? SEEING NO TESTIMONY. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1406 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE.
SB 1422 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR ALLEN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1422? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY. THIS IS A SUSPENSE.
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1422 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1450 BY SENATOR
ALLEN IS THERE. SENATOR ALLEN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1450? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1450. SEEING NO TESTIMONY. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES.
SO SB 1450 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
. MOVING ON TO SB 1151 BY
SENATOR HURTADO. SENATOR HURTADO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1151?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? I
MEAN, EXCUSE ME, IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1151. SEEING NEITHER THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1151 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1157 BY SENATOR HURTADO, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1157? YUSEF MILLER, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO AND MOSQUES
AGAINST TRAFFICKING SUPPORTS
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY, SB 1157 IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, IT WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO SB
1163 BY SENATOR DASCHLE, SENATOR
DOLLY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1163? ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1163? SEEING NO TESTIMONY.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
1160. SB 1163 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. OKAY. MOVING ON TO SB
1207 BY SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR
DOLLY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1207? ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1207? SEEING NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY OR NO TESTIMONY AT
ALL, THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB 1207,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE. SB 1188 BY SENATOR
LAIRD. SENATOR LAIRD HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1188? IS ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1188? I'M
SORRY. I MEANT TO STAND UP IN
SUPPORT OF YUSEF MILLER, NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION AND ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT THAT? I MISSED?
BACK TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1188? SEEING
NO OPPOSITION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1188 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1201
BY SENATOR DURAZZO, SENATOR
DURAZZO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1201? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1201. SEEING NO TESTIMONY. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1201 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1255 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL AS
WELL. THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
1255. YUSEF MILLER, ACTIVIST,
SAN DIEGO NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUSTICE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1255? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1255 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND SB 1325 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO. SENATOR DURAZZO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 12
1325? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1325. SEEING NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1325 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1220 BY
SENATOR LIMON. SENATOR LIMON HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1220?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1220. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE.
FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1220 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1376 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1376?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1376. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE AS
WELL. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1376 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1425 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1425? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1425. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1425 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1277 BY SENATOR STERN,
SENATOR STERN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1277? YUSEF
MILLER, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION AND ACTIVIST,
SAN DIEGO AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1277? SETH MORRISON WITH
JEWISH VOICE FOR PEACE. THIS
BILL USES STATE MONEY TO
EXCEPTIONALIZE THE JEWISH
HOLOCAUST AT THE EXPENSE OF ALL
THE OTHER HOLOCAUSTS THAT ARE
GOING ON, AND THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS COOPERATIVE, WHICH THIS
BILL ENSHRINES, IS BEEN STARTED
BY HOLOCAUST ORGANIZATIONS AND
OF THE 14 MEMBERS OF THIS GROUP,
SEVEN OF THEM, SEVEN OF THEM ARE
JEWISH HOLOCAUST ORGANIZERS,
WHICH MEANS IT WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ALL THE OTHER
GENOCIDES, ESPECIALLY THE ONE
GOING ON NOW IN IN GAZA, TO BE
TAUGHT TO OUR STUDENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. DANIEL
CHILDS ALSO WITH JEWISH VOICE
FOR PEACE FROM OAKLAND. I AM
JEWISH MYSELF. I ALSO OPPOSE
THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED. IT'S A
BIASED BILL, FUNDING BIASED
GROUPS AND EDUCATION THAT LEAD
TO RACISM. I MYSELF ONLY LEARNED
ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST GROWING UP.
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT ALL THESE
OTHER GENOCIDES, WHICH IS
HORRIBLE, SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR
THE HOLOCAUST IS NOT OKAY. IT'S
WORKING WITH BIASED GROUPS, AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID, THAT DON'T
RECOGNIZE THE CURRENT GENOCIDE
OF THE PALESTINIAN PEOPLE
RECOGNIZED BY THE ICJ. AND THESE
GROUPS REPRESENT THE INTERESTS
OF A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, NOT
ISRAEL, THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE
AMENDED TO TREAT ALL GENOCIDES
THE SAME AND NOT FINANCE BIASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN, IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF IT, THAT WOULD BE
GREAT, JASMINE BURKE, ACTIVIST
FROM OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA. I
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AS IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT IT BE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE EDUCATION
AROUND THE UNITED NATIONS,
INTERNATIONAL LAW AND THE
GENOCIDE CONVENTION, AND BE
NEUTRAL BY NOT PLACING ANY
EMPHASIS ON ANY GENOCIDE IN
PARTICULAR. THANK YOU. I'M CLYDE
LELAND FROM JEWISH VOICE FOR
PEACE IN BERKELEY. AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE BY
FUNDING THIS BILL, WE ARE
ACTUALLY PROMOTING A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF ANTI-SEMITISM BY
PRIORITIZING THE JEWISH
HOLOCAUST OVER ALL THE OTHER
GENOCIDE THAT HAS HAPPENED OVER
HISTORY AND THE ONE THAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW, WHICH
CAUSES PEOPLE TO RESENT THE
JEWISH PEOPLE AND THE INFLUENCE
THAT THEY HAVE. AND SO I AM
CALLING FOR THIS TO BE AMENDED
SO THAT MONEY IS NOT SPENT TO
MIS EDUCATE OUR YOUTH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MARIE
HOFF WITH JEWISH VOICE FOR PEACE
, SHASTA COUNTY I'M HERE TO
ENCOURAGE, THE AMENDING OF THIS
TO REFLECT A MORE ACCURATE,
RENDERING OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
GENOCIDE IN ORDER TO PROPERLY,
PUT OUR FUNDING TOWARDS A VIEW
OF GENOCIDE THAT IS JUST MORE
INCLUSIVE AND IS MORE ACCURATE,
AND THAT'S A MORE APPROPRIATE
USE OF FUNDING, IN MY OPINION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1277?
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
I APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1277 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1311 BY SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR STERN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
1311? GOOD MORNING. ALEJANDRO
SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN
POWER CAMPAIGN AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1311? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1311 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1509 BY SENATOR
STERN. SENATOR STERN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON ON THIS BILL, IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1509? ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1509. SEEING NEITHER. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1509 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1316 BY
SENATOR WAHAB. SENATOR WAHAB HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1316?
YUSEF MILLER, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION,
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS AND
ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1316? SEEING NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1316 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1328 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
AND FOR THAT I AM ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1328? YUSEF
MILLER, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION AND ACTIVIST,
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1328? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1328 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1415 BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1415? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1415. YUSEF
MILLER, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION, CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS AND ACTIVIST, SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT. OKAY. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1415 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1443 BY SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR JONES ALSO HAS
GRACIOUSLY WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON HIS BILL. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1443? YUSEF MILLER
, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION ACTIVIST, SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1443? THIS
BILL AGAIN, AS WELL AS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1443 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, SB 1465 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SENATOR ARCHULETA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON HIS BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
1465? IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1465? SEEING
NEITHER THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1465 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AND WITH THAT, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR TODAY.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING, AND, WE INVITE YOU TO
COME BACK WHEN WE DO OUR OUR BIG
FILE, WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
AND THE MEETING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION IS ADJOURNED